[Music]
alright guys I'm gonna show you a video
and you tell me your thoughts and I'm
pretty sure you've seen this videos
already what comes out of me when I see
these videos I just saw a peek of it and
I was just like ready
can I just react at Kevin's reaction I
saw this one oh it's so [ __ ] cringy
yeah cuz blacks not even in season right
black black dress is not even in season
[ __ ] them yeah so I wish he fold it up
and put it in a trash get up yeah so
there have been a lot of gives it back
to the protester be like influencers in
the wild kind of thing because there's
this one Twitter account that post a lot
of these here's another one oh please
tell me you have the one with the
[ __ ] chick that drought hold on we're
gonna get there but here's another one
there's a t-mobile that has been like
looted and she's taking a photo right of
how are you ever seen you're so [ __ ]
shameless and then here is what's wrong
one more example before we get into that
one so here is a screenshot from a a
close friends story of this one chick
and the conversation says like the
person she's texting is should we go to
protest and then this girl says I'm
located down and the only other one says
me - let's get drunk and go is that like
so dangerous
oh my god I'm so down let me find a riot
outfit oh right it outfit people see
later post photos of them at the the
protest in their riot outfit so this is
just if you don't think forever 21
wouldn't have a riot outfit automatic in
it they absolutely would they were now
called it that but it would
would mask and everything oh my gosh
Nike doesn't have riot shoes I think
Nikes gonna come out with the the hyper
fleece mass no the hyper boots mass
coming out I hope so
so this is done here's that famous video
what a bet your ego [ __ ] you by standard
by standard person saying they're like
oh good job guys oh she ends up saying
like Instagram boyfriend or something
like oh yeah and then as she this chick
closes the door like the windows folio
that's how we know it's not her saying
it but it's like someone else saying
like oh great job black legs or BLM oh
my gosh this is like the bane of my
existence why are people like this it's
just like yeah I think I part partially
feel responsible because I'm considered
an influencer yeah and people like do
this and like but that's gotta be like a
separate category category performance
it's it's optics that's literally just
it's fun he's using the hashtags and
[ __ ]
oh yeah we ain't been going for that
that's good we've been saying I don't
know if y'all seen this on your
timelines open your purse yeah yeah yeah
everybody open your purse means like
don't just make a state you got a donate
first and then let's see what your
Executive Board looks like not just like
anybody can put white letters on a black
image which is I was like one person was
writing all these yeah it was stuff you
don't like we at company X are
apologizing for what was it police
brutality against who the black people
please buy our stuff sincerely we want
to be on the right side of history yeah
you don't I mean I want to be on the
right side of the economy yeah hey we're
dead Denny's we're doing a black lives
matter sandwich whitney's get out
500,000 Legos donating a million that's
that's like real well Wendy's had some
rumors being spread about that
first yeah because that one dude who
owned like a whole bunch of Whitney's
and Taco Bell's in KFC said he don't
like to trump's presidency and when he
says I wallow fam that's that that's
Bendis was getting cancelled and Wendy's
was like yo yea and Wendy's whole
Twitter account is a black purse it's
black people like the way they talk is
is black people so they had to make a
distinction and I was sad I was like
come on Wendy's there the one is two
minutes of my house I need this I need
this
Wendy's Twitter is a black person oh man
you if you look how they talk and their
apology like we we wit the culture
period like just the lingo the way they
talk it's it's a it's a black person
matter
Wendy's released a mixtape like oh yeah
no Wendy's released some mixes who
they're like logo is yeah yeah we rock
with Dave man witness was there for poor
people for a long time yeah yeah I got
to college because it was like a little
bit richer more elevated upgraded the
exterior is from brick like all of them
look like they're from the 80s you're
thinking the McDonald's us cuz we just
have like the mom-and-pop like the the
grease pits and then we had like that
the [ __ ] the taco the kiddos and then
we just had McDonald's well according to
commercials only black hot people eat at
McDonald's black the black McDonald's
commercials are Oh bro yeah dribbling a
basketball way loops seen Arby's like we
don't just be doing that outside all at
once like it's like we just be hungry
and then I'm a black chick in it with a
with an afro and then she's like a size
one barely she's got like a McDonald's
burger hey the way companies market the
black people we just we just get hungry
just give us the prices that's all we
don't need a special black version of
like hey Bros there with McDonald's
version of
have you ever done that inside of
McDonald's you swear you've never done
you've never had a brochure inside of
McDonald's I don't adapt up in there but
I owe ya companies are sought a touch I
love I booked a Latin market McDonald's
commercial and like I wasn't in this
scene but that other scene they all had
to wear soccer uniforms no like it was
only for Latin America stereotype
service little thing like what do we
know about blacks basketball rap both of
them and the best thing too is when you
give like you give these they're all
actors right so you're like you give
them a Jersey like oh what's this team
no they don't follow sports like it's
the type of people then yeah all right
well going back to this chick with the
boarding up of the place so her name is
Fiona it was so funny because like
initially when this video went viral no
one knew who she was but then as soon as
it hit Twitter Twitter detectives
immediately found out what she was and
which one she see the drill detective is
no joke she's actually a UC Santa
Barbara senior they don't we don't know
none of those people are locals acceptor
yeah and then so she actually works as a
journalist which is a senior with the
Mercedes yeah it's probably a boyfriend
I don't know um yeah so she works as
like a journalist and she has
contributed to certain publications and
as soon as this came out though she
looked like didn't like Fiona facts or
something yeah so her Twitter handles
like Fiona fax oh thank gosh was that
asian or some with that yeah I thought
it was asian girls like Asian like chick
but actually looks like she looks like
like one of me she looks like one of me
big Mixy Mixy well her last name is more
i what is it
more ADT Moriarty more yards that's the
villain in Sherlock Holmes yep
what Moriarty that's Sherlock Holmes
number one villain she's a plant these
people do stuff like this like everybody
doesn't have a cell phone in their hand
yeah you know it's the it's the middle
of the day like you're gonna get
somebody's gonna post this and you're
like haha
but the likes oh didn't um was that
other influencer that did like a staged
shoot really out of a car yeah she uh I
don't want to call out the wrong person
oh I didn't see that at all but Oh beer
Madison beers she's a tick talker I
don't know what she does I just know
that she's like a hot girl and unlike a
lot of talk people like her tick tock
artists I don't know her very well she's
got a big following and she posted this
protest photo and it was like her and
like some of the people in there signs
and it looks like a regular protest
photo but then you see a
behind-the-scenes thing and they like
we're parked in the middle Street
stopping traffic like to pose for this
like big shoot like that
yeah there's no limit to what people
will do for cloud there's literally
nothing people won't do like our
protesting cool but they don't even
prompted me get like a fire selfie i'll
i respect you if you're like in the
people there like can we go to the edge
of the protest it was like behind her so
it looked like she was in it but the way
they set it up she was like behind the
protest thanks what is the fake help one
like the fake drill helping to clean up
it's like you're interrupting the person
who's actually really at work
a little bit like why did you let this
[ __ ] interrupted work because she's
white and like the date before Santa
Monica had gone like right like your
owners and like it was crazy so then
this guy was like boarding it up after
that if these people saw George Floyd on
the ground they'd be like getting
pictures there's nothing people would do
there's no limit to the dance of the
sign of like the taking the selfies with
the baby dolphins in China this is our
equivalent to that the America's
equivalent
it's like Nightcrawler my baby dolphins
were dying because they were taking
selfies with these baby dolphins water
take a picture real quick on the throne
back in mmm but then everyone wants to
turn so they're just out on the sand
like probably why we have all this covet
[ __ ] warnings because they're like
well you guys here are smart and you get
it you know but how great is this cuz I
guarantee you this should happen in the
60s and 70s on she said that I said that
I said you know like social media we
already made the world worse but you
just really have access to people's
thoughts and angles yeah Martin Luther
King like obviously he marched people
were with him but there are some people
like man that's dumb we should be yeah
yeah and I just didn't have Twitter like
there's nobody agrees with everything no
matter what you do someone thinks you're
stupid yeah people black people too like
obviously what my thing that I hate is
why people bein like man what Martin
Luther King do me only need another one
of him like you killed him yeah we did
forgot about well he was a white guy
with a gun though right oh I do have a
gun though okay
[Music]
you